te haya sido jornada muy importante aquí
en Turquía segunda vuelta de estas
elecciones donde los turcos y turcas
votan por primera vez en la historia de
Turquía en una segunda vuelta por lo
tanto Ya de por sí esto es un hecho
totalmente inédito en la historia del
país hoy la jornada ha transcurrido esta
jornada de votación ha transcurrido con
algo más de tensión
que la última vez que hace 15 días en la
primera vuelta los turcos hoy escogen
entre el que literal
hay mucha división en estas elecciones
ahora mismo ya se está produciendo el
conteo de los votos con más de un 80%
escrutado erdogan estaría encabezando
ahora mismo las elecciones que más que
literalu va algo por detrás en un
recuento independiente por parte de la
agencia privada anca el que iría por
delante es
que maquilita algo por detrás pero aún
no podemos establecer ninguna conclusión
porque el conteo se está produciendo más
de un 80% escrutado vamos a ver qué
ocurre con el 20% restante porque todo
está muy abierto Alberto estamos viendo
que el conteo avanza rápidamente verdad
sí Está avanzando mucho más rápido que
la última vez Tenemos que tener en
cuenta que hoy solamente se Escoge un
presidente en la vez anterior no
solamente había la primera vuelta de las
presidenciales también había que escoger
un parlamento por lo tanto el conteo
anterior fue mucho más lento hoy se está
produciendo de una forma mucho más
ligera por lo que se puede prever que
quizá en cosa de una o dos horas ya
podemos llegar a tener algún resultado
más definitivo como bien decía bueno el
conteo de los votos ya va por encima del
80 por ciento y la delantera la lleva el
mandatario receta allí erdoan de
mantenerse esta tendencia ingresarían su
tercera década en el poder hablábamos
recién del ambiente que se vive por allí
la oposición ya ha denunciado
irregularidades a lo largo de esta
jornada
sí como decíamos hoy estas elecciones
están transcurriendo con algo más de
tensión se han denunciado
irregularidades en algunos puntos de
votos son irregularidades que ha
denunciado la oposición
que ahora mismo nosotros no podemos
confirmar ni desmentir todas estas
irregularidades deben ser investigadas
debidamente también por entes
internacionales y sobre todo lo que hay
que ver es si estas irregularidades
varían en el resultado final de estas
elecciones de esta segunda vuelta
electoral de las presidenciales aquí en
Turquía